you know when i watch that disturbing
video what i think about it's very
simple i think about a question what
causes a man a grown man to be willing
to risk their lives to hang on to a c-17
that goes up on the sky and then you see
a body dropping
and dying what's worth you doing that
what are you trying to go to you're
trying to go to america for what for
better food
for better health care for better
entertainment what do you what do you
want to come here for what do you want
to escape afghanistan for or is it
because of freedom it's interesting
right that people are willing to risk
their lives for freedom
didn't a famous person just recently say
screw your freedom screw your freedom a
famous governor from california who has
been in movies was a celebrity who's
admired by millions including by myself
i grew up wanting to be this man who
said screw your freedom really see when
i watch that video what i think about it
reminds me of iran i was born in 78 the
year prior to that december 31st on new
year's eve jimmy carter the president of
the united states want to have a toast
with the shah
and it was looking so good that us's
iran are such good allies and then he
leaves and then khomeini sends his tapes
and it spreads like wildfire and next
thing you know iran starts going through
a revolution kissinger and carter said
we're going to help you out to shah
never did and then the last time he
called they said we can't help you it's
too late and what happened khomeini came
in took over similar scene identical
scene to the airport khomeini showed up
everybody was afraid but it was too late
what happened to iran the next 10 years
half a million lives could have been
saved by a decision made by jimmy carter
similar thing as a decision that could
have been made by president biden if the
approach would have been different we
could have saved many lives and do you
think the taliban are going to be done
and they're going to do all the good
things for women and children and all
the kids
it's going to be a free country what do
you think
do you think the taliban loves america i
don't know about that i think this video
more than anything else ought to remind
all of us in america how powerful
freedom is that millions on top of
millions of people around the world
are willing to give their lives to come
to america
[Music]